[Music]
he's back no one thought he would be
back but he is back alex smith
washington quarterback cleared for all
football
activities they had a great tweet over
the weekend and i i you can see it at
the washington football team's twitter
page i'm going to give it a little extra
a little extra salesmanship here because
my nephew anthony zeich is the one who
put it together it looks like a comic
book cover very well done he's getting a
lot of great freelance work from some
nfl teams based solely on merit because
he is extremely talented he's the one in
the family who actually has talent mike
that is for damn sure what one thing one
thing that just jumped out to me because
i like the washington new look right i
am a little i think what i realized this
weekend though i i miss i missed the big
like yellow and white and stripes down
the middle of the helmet so as much as i
like it like i'm i'm disappointed with
that i just thought i'd air that out
sorry i they're not on there still no
it's i don't know all maroon with just
that yellow gold number and the yellow
gold you know face mask so
it still works whatever they're doing it
works it does work and if they if they
have a decent season this year i have a
feeling washington football team is
going to be the name at least for
another season or two all right remains
to be seen whether or not alex smith
ends up being the starting quarterback
the key though is he's in the mix and
that comeback makes him the inspiration
for today's draft the best all-time
individual comeback stories i've got the
trivia question for christopher who was
the only player to receive the comeback
player of the year award twice chris
wow gosh i know i know this too and i
just man
nfl comeback player of the uh
all right i don't know it go ahead
chad pennington oh
chad penny oh i knew it 2006 with the
jets and two years later with the
dolphins because uh he landed in miami
after the jets ended up with brett favre
so twice for chad pennington all right i
get the first pick then and there are
many to choose from
um
given the impact of the player and given
what he did after he came back and given
that it looked like he was done i got to
go with peyton manning i've got to i'm
assuming we're leaving alex smith out of
this yeah i gotta go with peyton manning
right
the four surgeries the neck problems the
atrophy of the triceps the question as
to whether he could even throw the ball
again
and and the colts just said forget it
we're done
we're we're moving on to andrew luck
who's going to be our quarterback for
the next 15 years oh maybe not
but they didn't even hesitate to move on
from peyton manning and uh
and it worked yeah
it healed he could throw he could throw
well enough he set records after he came
back the irony is that it was only after
he was completely falling apart
otherwise physically that's when he
finally won his second super bowl yeah
but that 2013 season was a was a special
all-time season two years after the the
lost season to the next surgeries so uh
that one given who he was given what he
overcame given would have been very easy
for him to just walk away after
everything he'd accomplished you throw
all that together and it's one of the
great comebacks we've ever seen yeah no
no doubt about it you know i think when
you i mean just amazing yeah we thought
oh no is he ever going to play again is
he ever going to be the same to
holy cow he's setting the nfl on fire
here with you know four and five
touchdowns a week and they were just
unstoppable on the offensive side of the
ball so good pick by you i'm not mad at
you i think i gotta go kurt warner with
mine you know because kurt warner to me
like did it twice
you know first off all right yeah he was
you know the giants he went to the
giants they drafted eli manning you're
thinking oh man it's over kurt warner
he's done he goes to arizona and like
has this revival of his career but
really
like i how about the first one you know
you're not on a team you gotta go back
to northern i you know green bay cuts
you you go back to northern iowa you
know you're you're bagging groceries and
then all of a sudden you're you know
playing for the rams and the greatest
show on turf and a super bowl mvp and
the nfl mvp you know that that to me
even though it's not an injury or
anything like that still
is an unbelievable comeback story times
two really and especially that first
part with him you know being cut by
green bay
yeah i mean he really bounced around and
it was a show of that that drive and
that motivation and he had the
opportunities he played for the iowa
barnstormers he played in nfl europe or
whatever name it had at the time it had
seven different names during its life
those opportunities aren't there and
especially this year with no preseason
games limited chances for guys to get to
get film of what they can do and to show
that they can perform these stories are
going to be fewer and farther between
where it was a guy who comes out of
nowhere and really turns it around it's
going to be somebody else who gets those
opportunities because it's going to be
harder to prove yourself to that that's
a good choice by you next one for me
eric barry the chief safety who overcame
cancer and came back and played shame he
wasn't with the chiefs last year when
they won the super bowl
uh maybe they'll give him a ring we're
still trying to find out when the rings
are going to be distributed by the
chiefs they're they're finalizing the
plans i think very soon for giving them
out but eric barry
anytime something like this happens
where you have a high profile
cancer patient it can inspire so many
others who deal with that battle who
deal with that adversity and need
someone
that they can point to
as their source of inspiration and you
know my mom went through it years ago
like jim valvano was the guy that she
sure she used as her inspiration you
find somebody who's in a high profile
setting who is doing it and who is doing
it well and who overcomes it and and
that's and for him to come back play in
the nfl after beating cancer it just
it's it to me it resonates uh because i
think it's so important when you have
someone in a platform like that who does
fight it and beat it
and and help others who are dealing with
it every single day yeah just a great
way about him and you know yeah
unbelievable you know to deal with that
come back play as well as he did
you know then of course unfortunate to
get hurt once again and hurt his you
know is what achilles i believe or
whatever it was week one week one what
was it week one twenty seventeen years
yeah that was a shame that really was
but yeah that was one of the better
stories we've had here in the nfl over
the last four or five years and uh hope
he's doing okay and continuing to fight
the good fight there
all right
i'm gonna go john riggins with my second
one okay
good old john rigo okay you know rigo
1980 he wanted more money he and he said
oh all right fine not gonna give me more
money the hell with this i'm not playing
for this washington team and he
basically took the year off and then he
came back and said i'm bored i'm broke
i'm back
in 1981 he comes back and they go to the
super bowl and he wins super bowl mvp
you know again it's not like your
typical comeback story after injuries or
you know life-threatening disease
anything like that but damn i don't know
it just tells you what kind of a
freaking nature john riggins was you
talk about legs and butt first off he's
he had it and yeah to be able to running
back to take a year off you know in the
prime of your career and then come back
and just kick butt again that's pretty
damn impressive so
i'm going with john riggins there in
pick two
yeah that one's uh that one's an
interesting pick i'm not in the mood
today to knock your picks it's creative
thank you thank you i'm gonna give you
i'm gonna give you a gold star for that
and uh riggins was an all-time great
character and it's great he came back
they needed him in that super bowl where
he uh turned the fourth and one into the
touchdown that was the moment that
really delivered it for the team next
one for me this is one we talk about
from time to time when we talk about the
pro bowl even though it didn't happen in
the stadium it's the incident that
happened at the
beach two-hand touch football game 1988
season robert edwards the horrific knee
injury that almost resulted in
amputation he was told at the time he'd
have to walk with a cane for the rest of
his life now he didn't come back
and become a star
but he made it back at the running back
position he came back which is
incredible yeah robert edwards after
that injury as bad as it was a severed
artery and ligaments torn and they
seriously thought they were going to
have to amputate the leg playing beach
football for him to be able to come back
and put on an nfl uniform is tremendous
and it's the closest thing i can think
of to this alex smith situation yeah
that was uh nasty i mean i can remember
that as a kid watching that pro bowl
event and just seeing all their legs get
tangled up and him rolling there and
going oh man uh but that that was
serious and unbelievable that he came
back to even you know get snaps in the
nfl like you said uh so that was a good
one by you i did not have him written
down i had kind of forgotten that one so
uh all right you trying to challenge my
johnny creativeness this morning good
for you all right
well i got another one for you i think
you're gonna like this one
rocky blyer i'm going with rocky blyer
guy gets drafted
literally into the nfl and then
literally gets drafted to go to a war
the vietnam war and then comes back and
has a huge role for the pittsburgh
steelers and goes on to play there all
those great years you know sharing time
with with franco harris and everything
like that to win four super bowls and of
course have that one awesome touchdown
catch in the super bowl and everything
like that uh which i believe was super
bowl 10 against the cowboys and maybe
that was super bowl 13. i can't remember
it was one of the cowboy ones but i mean
that to me when i just was looking up
comeback stories then you know you don't
hear that every day would you so what
happened to your pro career well i had
to go to war in vietnam for a while and
then i came back to play football i mean
that's freaking amazing so uh and he got
injured he got injured right right yeah
he was he was shot in the left thigh by
an enemy bullet damn and uh while he was
down an enemy grenade landed nearby
after bouncing off of a fellow soldier
sending shrapnel into his lower right
leg he lost part of his right foot wow
and came back and played in the nfl
chris so uh
yeah yeah
your research didn't uncover that little
tidbit which makes it even more
impressive others that i had others i
had i had frank gifford who took that
wicked hit from concrete charlie bedner
that knocked him out for a full year he
came back and played after that rod
woodson torn acl week one 1995 against
the detroit lions came back and played
that year in the super bowl remember
after he made a play he got up and he
taunted
the only time in the nfl that anyone's
ever taunted anyone by pointing at their
knee that's what rod woodson did in
super bowl 30. and then drew brees yep
drew brees after the 2005 season his
last game as a charger his shoulder got
messed up that's why the dolphins didn't
want him they gave up a second round
pick to get dante culpepper that year
instead of the free agent who had 20
plus studs in his shoulder the dolphins
wouldn't touch him
amazing the saints roll the dice and
they end up with one of the great
quarterbacks of all time chris yeah i
mean drew brees that was the one that
was hard to me you know hard for me not
to pick there in the draft because that
is i mean he went to like ooh can he
ever be a starting quarterback to like
throwing for 5 000 yards every year
which was which is unbelievable also had
i also thought about brady you know with
his four game suspension coming back you
know only bringing the team back from 28
to three and then win the super bowl
that year joe montana right i mean he
was not play he didn't play football for
you know basically a year and then went
to the kansas city chiefs and made them
relevant and went to the playoffs and
all that and then i even had michael
vick on my list too you know hey
whatever you want to say i don't like
the circumstances that led up to that
delay but michael vicks still came back
when 10-6 as a pro bowl that was pretty
unbelievable too
and i got to give our friend mike downs
in ironbridge a shout out from sky
sports pointing out teddy bridgewater we
didn't mention it how could we forget
teddy bridges no doubt the horrific acl
tear four years ago and now he's the
starting quarterback of the carolina
panthers at a time when few thought he
would come back and play at a high level
in the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports